in this video we would look at electron
transport chain and oxidative
phosphorylation before we begin let's
just refresh our memory about the
mitochondrial structure so mitochondria
has two membranes the outer membrane and
the inner membrane the inner membrane is
invaginate 'add forming the Christie or
crista and in between these two membrane
there is an inter membrane space inside
the inter membrane inner membrane there
is mitochondrial matrix now inside the
matrix there is DNA and ribosomes now
let's talk about the inner membrane and
the components in the inner membrane
because inner membrane is pretty
difficult from the outer membrane and
inner membrane has the electron
transport chain and the machinery for
ATP production the ATP synthase so let
me introduce you to the component of the
electron transport chain there are four
different complexes named as NADH
dehydrogenase or the complex one
succinate dehydrogenase or the complex
two cytochrome bc1 complex or otherwise
known as complex 3 cytochrome c oxidase
or otherwise known as complex 4 in
between these two complex in these
complexes there are several electron
carriers such as coenzyme q sign
cytochrome c now after that there's a
huge motor which is known as the ATP
synthase now ATP synthase is super
important for generation of the ATP and
we would look at it so there are two
components here in this whole system one
is the electron transport chain which
comprises of all these four complexes
and the ATP generator which involves the
ATP synthase motor now we would
understand about the electron transport
chain in next 30 seconds it's damn easy
and how the electron transport chain or
transportation of the electron is
involved with a temperature
we would also understand that in next 30
seconds so let's begin the electron
transport chain and the ATP generator
generation machinery is lot similar to a
electric plant now in the electric plant
there would be a fuel combustion unit
and the fuel combustion unit is
connected with a power generator so the
full fuel would be burned and using that
energy there with some kind of rotor or
some kind of converter which would
convert that energy to electrical energy
similarly in case of the electron
transport chain the fuel combustion unit
is the electron transport chain here the
electrons from nadh and fadh2 and forted
across these complexes now these
electrons are later on used in the
complex for to reduced oxygen and to
form water now while these electron
transfer is going on simultaneously
there are protons which are pumped into
the intermembrane space and after
several rounds of proton pumping there
is quite a lot of proton accumulation
into the intermembrane space that builds
up a proton gradient now this proton
gradient has or otherwise it has a
profit motive force inside so using that
proton motive force the rotor or the ATP
synthase or a trapeze generator can
generate ATP and that's how the energy
in the proton motive force is converted
into the bond energy of inside ATP and
which is generated combining ADP and
inorganic phosphate so this is the
clear-cut idea about the electron
transport chain and the oxidative
phosphorylation so the electron
transport chain is a relay system by
which you it is like relaying electron
among themselves and ultimately reducing
oxygen to water
and the ATP generation machinery is
another component which is kind of
dependent on electron transport chain
because electron transport chain helped
to build the proton gradient and using
that proton gradient or proton motive
force the adb generator generates
high-energy bond in format of ATP and
ATP is the currency for the cell so that
was clear about the electron transport
chain and oxidative phosphorylation now
let us look at this whole process in lot
more details so first we come to the
complex one which is otherwise known as
NADH dehydrogenase the name C is pretty
simple right NADH dehydrogenase it looks
like a dehydrogenation reaction so
definitely the hydrogenation reaction
means the oxidation reaction where NADH
would be oxidized to nad now since it's
an oxidation reaction so electron would
be removed and the removed electron from
NADH is moved through this complex one
and ultimately it moves to coenzyme q
coenzyme q is a mobile electron carrier
which would transfer this to the next
complex now if we look into the
mitochondrial matrix there are proton
ions which would be pumped actually for
proton ions would be pumped into the
intermembrane space looking into the
detailed structure of nadh dehydrogenase
we can see there is a membrane bound
region and there is a region which is
put rooting outside from the membrane in
the matrix NADH is converted to nad the
electron which is ejected from NADH
first goes to a flavin mononucleotide
Center from there it at least moves
through seven iron sulfur clusters and
after moving through this iron sulfur
clusters these electrons are transferred
to coenzyme q now the coenzyme q would
diffuse through the membrane and take
these excess this this electron to the
next complex which
the cytochrome bc1 complex cytochrome
bc1 complex has three major components
cytochrome B centrum c1 and the risky
iron
iron-sulfur cluster the kokyu gives his
electron to this big complex and the
electron moves through cytochrome B then
cytochrome C and ultimately it reaches
the risky iron sulfur complex in that
risky ions are from complex the electron
is then transferred to cytochrome C
which is another mobile carrier of
electron cytochrome C would transfer
that to the next complex but in the same
process four hydrogen ions are pumped to
the intermembrane space cytochrome C
takes this electron and gives it to
complex 4 complex 4 has three major
component three major subunits and it
has to him my T's and a copper ion as
well
electrons are shipped sequentially
transferred through these centers and
ultimately get combined with water with
oxygen to form water so we can clearly
see oxygen is reduced to water by the
action of cytochrome C oxidase or
complex 4 activity in this process also
for hydrogen ions are transported to the
intermembrane space and we can clearly
understand there are quite a lot of
hydrogen ion or quite a lot of proton is
now accumulated in the intermembrane
space as if a proton gradient has been
formed more protons in the intermembrane
space and less proton in the matrix side
now this proton gradient or the energy
present in this proton gradient is
utilised by the ATP synthase now these
protons come down here from this
gradient through these ATP synthase
allow this ATP synthase motor to rotate
and that mechanical energy is
transformed into a chemical energy and
stored inside the bonds of ATP and
ultimately with the help of inorganic
phosphate and ADP ATP
is produced and the energy in proton
motive force or the proton gradient is
stored inside the chemical in in a
chemical nature inside the ATP the ATP
synthase complex is pretty interesting
and complex it has several subunits and
components but if we try to understand
the mechanism by which it generates ATP
it would be really sophisticated so
there are a lot of hydrogen binding
sites in the transmembrane domains now
while hydrogen is binding this trans
membrane ceiling rotates and as it
rotates one by one hydrogen's are
released into the mitochondrial matrix
now using that force the the head region
of these ATP synthase complex also
rotate and that leads to production of
ATP one rotation can even produce three
molecules of ATP as depicted in this
animation and that is how ATP is
generated using the proton motive force
which is actually the proton motive
force was built using the electron
transport chain and that is how inside
the mitochondria ATP is generated so I
hope you enjoyed this introductory video
about electron transport chain and
oxidative phosphorylation I hope this
video was informative as well so if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe but in a next video I would
really cover these topics in lot more
details and this was just an
introductory video so stay tuned and
thank you for watching to let me know in
the comments how you like my videos bye